Yo Taylor, I’m really happy for you, Ima
let you finish.
But Beyonce had one of the best videos of
all time.
Kanye West’s interruption of Taylor Swift’s
acceptance speech at the MTV video music awards
was shocking, but crazy antics like this are
par for the course for Kanye West.
It’s just Kanye being Kanye.
Yet that moment in 2009 is nothing compared
to his latest controversies.
Kanye West has single-handedly destroyed all
that he has worked so hard to achieve.
The final nail in the coffin came just after
Elon Musk lifted his ban and he was welcomed
back to Twitter.
He then got himself kicked off again after
tweeting out a photo of a swuh-stika symbol
inside a Star of David, which we’ve blurred
because it’s not appropriate to show.
Musk said the rapper violated the platform’s
rule against prohibiting incitement to violence.
Kanye’s career is officially up in flames.
And you can forget about him running for President
in 2024…not that anyone took him seriously.
His fall from grace has actually been years
in the making.
In 2018, things appeared to be going well
for Kanye West.
He seemed happy with his wife Kim Kardashian
and was preparing to release a new album.
But take a closer look, and there were noticeable
cracks.
His album Ye was delayed repeatedly before
finally being released to less than glowing
reviews.
He would officially change his name to just
Ye, with no last name.
There were indications on the album cover
of Ye that something wasn’t quite right.
He apparently snapped this photo of the mountains
in Wyoming on his iPhone and scribbled the
words: “I hate being bipolar, it’s awesome.”
Kanye was diagnosed with bipolar disorder
in 2016.
According to the American Psychiatric Association,
people with the mental illness can experience
“intense emotional states” which can result
in “risky behavior”.
Ye’s state of mind was pretty evident.
After his flurry of antisemitic posts on Instagram,
which got removed, he took to Twitter to lash
out at Instagram’s CEO Mark Zuckerberg.
But then he got banned on Twitter in December.
And switched back to Instagram, where he bizarrely
accused Musk of being a half-Chinese genetic
hybrid.
The same week he got booted from Twitter - he
appeared on conspiracy theorist Alex Jones’
show wearing a full black mask, in which he
made it known that he liked Hitler, that he
had a lot of redeeming qualities, and he denied
the Holocaust ever happened.
Some even remarked that he made Alex Jones
look sane for once!
He kept up the full face mask look for a subsequent
interview on Censored.tv.
How many times do I have to prove, how many
times do I have to do something like so miraculous
for people to see that it’s brilliant, that
it’s not mental health.
Like me wearing a mask gives me this ability
to not have to worry about showing my face
so I can think about what I am saying.
There was also the time he recently stormed
off political commentator Tim Pool’s podcast
after Pool appeared to challenge his negative
views of Jewish people.
You leaving?
https://www.mirror.co.uk/3am/us-celebrity-news/kanye-west-stands-luxury-fashion-28635653
He went out the door, and so, it seems, has
his entire career.
He’s gone.
It would take a miracle for him to make a
comeback after all that’s happened.
And he’s already been gifted a miracle once
before when he nearly died.
In 2002, after a late night at a studio in
California, he fell asleep at the wheel and
collided with another vehicle, shattering
his jaw.
His jaw was wired to his face during reconstructive
surgery…which inspired his hit single “Through
the Wire”.
Up until then, he had long been boxed in as
a producer, and was never taken seriously
as a rapper.
But the car crash hit him with a burst of
creativity.
His 2004 debut album College Dropout received
critical acclaim with tracks like Jesus Walks.
And then he kept rising.
His sixth studio album, Yeezus, was out of
this world.
West seemed unstoppable.
And so, apparently, was his ego.
He called himself the next Steve Jobs - a
visionary.
At one point, he was believed to be the wealthiest
musician on the planet.
Forbes estimated that he had a net worth of
$2 billion in 2022 before it all came crashing
down.
Adidas stopped selling his Yeezy sneakers
because of his antisemitic rants.
Gap cut ties with him.
So did Balenciaga, the fashion house he controversially
stood up for when it launched an ad campaign
with children holding teddy bears in bondage
gear.
Behind the eyebrow raising rants lay a troubled
man whose manic episodes had concerned his
then-wife.
In 2020, Kim Kardashian posted an Instagram
Story about his bipolar disorder for the first
time.
“Anyone who has this or has a loved one
in their life who does, knows how incredibly
complicated and painful it is to understand.”
She said she felt the need to speak out publicly
"because of the stigma and misconceptions
about mental health.”
Kardashian also mentioned that the “painful
loss of his mother” greatly affected him.
Kanye was incredibly close to his mum Dr.
Donda West, an English professor at Chicago
State University.
She died unexpectedly of a heart attack in
2007 at the age of just 58 after getting several
cosmetic surgeries.
He named his 2021 album after her.
The album had no cover art; it was simply
a black square.
Kardashian ended her Instagram post by pleading
that the media and the public give her family
the compassion and empathy needed to get through
this.
Instead of the spotlight, instead of being
surrounded by people telling him how great
he was, instead of fame, fortune, and fans,
Kanye needed…help.
It’s difficult to see someone go from the
highest of highs to the lowest of lows.
His breakdown has caused him to lose everything
that our society seems to cherish.
Fortune.
Power.
Status.
Influence.
Kim and Kanye also split in 2021 after six
years of marriage and four children.
Kanye West has a song on his fifth album called
Lost in the World.
It begins with the lyrics:
“I'm up in the woods
I'm down on my mind
I'm building a still
To slow down the time”
It’s about those who want to stop and clear
their minds to find themselves.
Perhaps a lesson for himself.
With the controversy surrounding him, and
brands dropping him left, right, and center,
Kanye West is reportedly no longer a billionaire.
Many billionaires have found alternative ways
to grow their wealth with the stock market
looking shaky.
A recent survey found many financial advisors
are branching out from the typical portfolio
of stocks and bonds.
My sponsor, Masterworks, offers a unique asset
that the uber-rich have invested in…and
now, you can to.
I’m talking about art.
Contemporary art has outpaced the S&P 500
by 131% over the last 26 years.
With Masterworks, you can invest in legendary
art from Picasso, Basquiat, Banksy…by buying
shares in these works.
So you don’t have to spend millions on their
paintings.
Six of Masterworks’ nine recent sales delivered
a net return to investors of over 21%!
Demand is so high, Masterworks is looking
to acquire new artwork every week…
Nearly 600,000 people have signed up so far
including many of my viewers.
So there is a waitlist.
But you can get priority access by signing
up with my custom link in the description.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I'm Cindy Pom.